.
Er ist seit 17 Jahren Polizist.
Sie sind mitten in der Ausbildung
und kommen an ihre Grenzen.
Ein Beinschlag nach dem anderen.
Es nicht im Griff haben -
das mag ich nicht.
Oh, da liegt jemand.
Mir rollte der Körper entgegen.
Go, go, go!
Stopp! Polizei!
Mit Untertiteln von SWISS TXT
Jemand
wurde mit einem Messer bedroht.
Jetzt muss es schnell gehen -
wie so oft
im Alltag von Yves Chappuis
von der Polizei Basel-Landschaft.
Ja, okay. Der Meldeerstatter
ist im Gebiet der Migros.
* Polizeisirene *
Wie viel hat dieser Alltag
mit den Vorstellungen
seiner jungen Kolleginnen
und Kollegen zu tun,
die neu in den Beruf einsteigen?
Er hat zu Ihnen so gemacht?
- Ja.
Okay.
Und dann habe der Unbekannte
plötzlich eine Waffe gezogen.
Er hat eine Pistole gezogen
und sie gegen Sie gerichtet?
Ja.
Ja, verstanden. Wir haben Kontakt
zum Meldeerstatter.
Er wollte seine Frau abholen.
Er hatte Kontakt
zu einem 2 m grossen Mann.
Dieser trug eine rote Jacke,
ein schwarzes Baseballcap
und schwarze Jogginghosen.
Er zog eine Waffe und bedrohte ihn.
* Laute Schreie *
Was ist dort drüben los?
Was ist dort los?
* Spannungserzeugende Musik *
Woher kommt das?
Bedroht der Mann mit der Waffe
in diesem Moment weitere Personen?
Zentrale 1102.
Ist alles gut, oder was?
Nein, es gab ein Gegentor.
Wir schauen das Spiel.
Was?
- Entschuldigung!
Deswegen schreit ihr so rum?
Macht das nicht! Ei, ei, ei!
Okay.
Jugendliche,
die auf dem Handy Fussball geguckt
und sich über ein Goal gefreut haben.
Das passt gerade zum Fall.
Super, oder?
Das können sie
natürlich nicht wissen.
So, also, sie haben geschrien,
weil ein Tor fiel.
Okay.
Ich melde mich bei Ihnen,
sobald wir mehr wissen -
wegen der Anzeige usw.
Ich habe Ihre Kontaktdaten.
Alles Weitere sehen wir dann.
Wir schauen,
ob wir jemanden feststellen können.
* Spannungserzeugende Musik *
Wir wollen hier mal kurz nachsehen.
Sonst gehen wir zum Fahrzeug.
Mhm.
Wo ist der Mann mit der Waffe?
Guten Abend.
* Spannungserzeugende Musik *
Da ist etwas Action im Hauseingang,
aber ...
Sonst gehen wir wirklich
zum Fahrzeug und schauen,
ob wir etwas antreffen.
- Er kann überall sein.
Ja.
* Spannungserzeugende Musik *
Gehst du vorne herum?
- Ja, ich mache eine Runde.
Yves Chappuis und sein Partner
fahnden im Auto weiter.
Das ist dermassen speziell:
Er will seine Frau abholen.
Dann zeigt ihm einer den Vogel
und zieht eine Waffe.
Aus welchem Grund?
Er hat keine Geldforderung gestellt
oder sonst irgendetwas.
Er hat ihm
auch sonst keine Gewalt angetan.
Es gibt keinen Grund.
Das Ganze ist nicht plausibel.
Yves Chappuis sucht vergebens weiter.
Der Mann mit der Waffe
ist spurlos verschwunden.
* Spannungserzeugende Musik *
Das Luzerner Seetal.
Hier lassen
die Polizei Basel-Landschaft
und zehn weitere Kantone
aus der Zentral- und Nordwestschweiz
ihren Nachwuchs ausbilden.
Heute steht die sog. Kaltwasserübung
auf dem Programm.
Vor dieser Herausforderung
haben viele grossen Respekt.
* Spannungserzeugende Musik *
Ich bin etwas nervös.
Ich bin gespannt, was mich erwartet.
Ich habe noch nicht
ins Wasser gefasst.
Es wird im ersten Moment
schon ein Schock sein.
Aber ich bin zuversichtlich,
dass es klappt.
Also, Nando, du gehst rückwärts
langsam ins Wasser
und konzentrierst dich
einfach aufs Atmen,
dass du langsam einatmest.
Beim Ausatmen kannst du die Luft
durch den Mund pressen.
Und nicht
auf die Kälte konzentrieren,
sondern nur aufs langsame Atmen.
Bleib ganz ruhig.
Schön langsam runter.
Und runter. Gut ein- und ausatmen.
Sehr gut, Nando.
- Du kannst zu Simon schauen.
So, Nando, schau mich an!
Schau mich an!
Atme ruhig! Atme flüssig!
* Nando atmet laut. *
Atme langsamer.
Jetzt ist es besser.
Okay. Alles klar, Nando?
Wir schwimmen los.
Alles klar.
Ruhig schwimmen.
Behalte einfach dein Tempo.
Und kontrolliere deine Atmung.
Das ist das Wichtigste.
Hör tief auf deine eigene Atmung.
Das Wasser ist 3 °C kalt.
Die Aufgabe des Baselbieters
Nando Wüthrich:
Er soll aus 2,5 m Tiefe
eine Puppe heraufholen.
Sehr gut, Nando.
Du kannst loslassen.
* Spannungserzeugende Musik *
Das Szenario: Die Puppe steht
für ein vier Jahre altes Mädchen,
das ins eiskalte Wasser fällt
und zu ertrinken droht.
Jetzt gehst du raus und reanimierst,
wenn du die Maske aufgesetzt hast.
Ja.
Nando Wüthrich
muss die Puppe an Land bringen,
einen Funkspruch absetzen und sofort
mit der Wiederbelebung anfangen.
Merci.
- Super!
Super. Jawohl.
- Einsatzzentrale von Patrouille 1:
Wir haben hier
ein vierjähriges Mädchen,
das in den See gefallen ist.
Ich musste sie aus 20 m vom Seeufer
in 2,5 m Tiefe holen.
Wir beginnen mit der Reanimation.
Super. Das ist perfekt.
- ... 17, 18, 19, 20.
Ich bin froh, dass es vorbei ist.
Aber es war eine gute Erfahrung.
Man darf das kalte Wasser
nicht unterschätzen,
gerade im ersten Moment.
Ich dachte, ich hätte das Atmen
besser unter Kontrolle.
Aber im ersten Moment merkte ich,
wie die Stockatmung einsetzt.
Da musste ich mich zusammenreissen
und sagen:
"Jetzt musst du dir Mühe geben,
sonst wird das nichts."
Ich bin froh, dass es
gut gelaufen ist. Ich bin zufrieden.
Bist du bereit?
- Ja.
Noch ein kleiner Tipp:
- Den Kragen schliessen?
Ja, dann läuft dir das Wasser
nicht oben rein.
Sonst hast du wieder die Konvektion
und es läuft oben in die Uniform.
So hältst du das kalte Wasser fern.
Also ...
- Gut. Viel Erfolg.
Jetzt gehe ich einfach so rein?
- Ja. Dreh dich um.
Genau.
Jetzt gehst du zuerst in die Knie.
Okay.
- Jetzt gehst du in die Hüfte.
Du stemmst dich in die Hüften
und gehst mit den Füssen rein.
Okay.
- Ja, genau so.
Ja.
- Leg dich auf den Boden. Ja.
Shit, ist das kalt.
- Geh langsam rein.
Denk an die Atmung! Langsam runter.
Schau zu mir! Schau zu mir!
Oh Gott!
- Jana, schau zu mir!
Schau zu mir!
* Spannungserzeugende Musik *
Sehr gut. Schau zu mir, Jana!
Du kannst dich hier festhalten.
Schau zu mir! Alles gut.
Alles gut.
- Oh Gott!
Langsam.
Es ist alles gut. Alles gut.
Genau so: fokussieren. Es ist
nur ein Auftrag. Nur ein Auftrag.
Du musst nur diese Person rausholen.
Für die Baselbieterin Jana Stierli
ist die Kaltwasserübung eine Tortur.
Okay. Es ist nur am Anfang so,
wenn du unter Wasser bist.
Versuch es nochmals.
Bei ihr ist heute der Wurm drin.
Auch die Puppe,
die sie heraufholen sollte,
erwischt sie nicht beim ersten Mal.
Jetzt schön ruhig.
Ein Beinschlag nach dem anderen.
Für Jana Stierli ist die Kaltwasser-
übung eine traumatische Erfahrung.
Lass ihn sein! Ist gut.
Als ich dann mit dem Körper reinkam,
brach es in mir zusammen -
in mir selber.
Vielleicht
verspürte ich auch Todesangst:
"Oje, sterbe ich jetzt? Was
passiert? Ich schaffe das nicht."
So viele Gedanken
gingen mir durch den Kopf.
"Ich schaffe es nicht.
Warum mache ich das jetzt?"
"Soll ich aufgeben oder nicht?"
"Nein, ich kann nicht aufgeben."
"Jetzt muss ich
noch zu ihm hochschauen."
Dann kamen einfach die Tränen.
Ich konnte sie auch nicht mehr
selber stoppen. Sie kamen einfach.
Vielleicht brauchte es das auch.
Ich weiss es nicht.
* Fröhliche Musik *
Das Tessin.
Das ist Jana Stierlis Kraftort.
Ihre Familie
besitzt hier ein Ferienhaus.
Die Kaltwasserübung
brachte die 22-Jährige,
die sonst immer so souverän wirkt,
an ihre Grenzen.
Ich denke,
es gibt sicher Situationen,
in denen ich
auch durchaus Schwächen habe.
Es nicht im Griff zu haben -
das mag ich nicht.
Ich habe es doch gerne im Griff.
Man kann nicht alles perfekt
meistern. Jeder hat seine Schwächen.
Ich finde es auch schön,
wenn man seine Schwächen zeigen
und zugeben kann:
"Darin bin ich nicht gut."
Es ist wichtig,
diese Schwächen zu erkennen,
damit man in Ernstsituationen weiss:
"Hier muss ich aufpassen."
* Fröhliche Musik *
Jana Stierli reiste für ein
verlängertes Wochenende ins Tessin -
zusammen mit ihrem Partner,
der sich noch gut an den Abend
nach der Kaltwasserübung erinnert.
Als ich zu ihr kam, sah ich,
dass es noch zwei Videos gab,
wie das genau ablief.
Dann fiel mir schon
die Kinnlade runter, als ich sah,
wie sie kämpfen musste
und wie das zu- und herging.
Ich begriff auch nicht wirklich,
wie kalt dieses Wasser wirklich war.
Ich war etwas schockiert.
Aber ich denke,
es ist halt einfach ein harter Teil
einer harten Ausbildung.
Aber ich glaube, du hast es geahnt.
Du weisst ja noch,
mein erster Tag ...
Ja. Ich würde sagen, Vorfreude
ist das falsche Wort für das,
was du verspürtest.
- Ja.
Aber ich glaube, ich hätte mich
mental besser vorbereiten können.
Ich hatte immer
eine negative Einstellung.
Ja, aber man kann sich mental
nicht auf alles vorbereiten.
Aber man könne nachher darüber reden,
sagt Jana Stierli.
Das sei wichtig für die Verarbeitung.
Vielen Dank fürs Tischen.
- Gerne.
Ich habe noch die Sauce
bereitgestellt.
An der Interkantonalen Polizeischule
in Hitzkirch/LU
trainieren Nando Wüthrich
und seine Kollegen
heute den Einsatz des sog.
Geraden Einsatzstockes, kurz GES.
* Spannungserzeugende Musik *
Ein wichtiger Punkt,
den ich euch mitgeben will:
Platziert den GES diagonal!
Beim horizontalen Block
besteht die Gefahr,
dass wir
in den Halsbereich abrutschen,
was schwere Verletzungen
zur Folge haben kann.
Das wollen wir nicht.
Wir platzieren ihn diagonal.
So! Und dann diagonal und stossen.
Nando Wüthrich lernt,
wie man physische Gewalt einsetzt.
Gleichzeitig muss er später
im Ernstfall abschätzen,
was verhältnismässig ist.
Und jetzt
noch aus der Angriffsachse raus.
Die Bewegung ist gut.
Komm aus der Angriffsachse raus!
Hier bleibst du
in der Angriffsachse.
Voilà!
Also, wenn du verdrängt hast ...
Jetzt bin ich aus der Angriffsachse.
Fehleinschätzungen können fatale
Folgen haben - für ihn und andere.
Oh!
Fehler können zu schweren Ver-
letzungen oder sogar zum Tod führen -
bei einer Auseinandersetzung
oder bei einer Verhaftung.
Ja, genau.
Und jetzt noch etwas spritziger
und schneller.
Ja, genau.
Und aus der Angriffsachse raus.
Sehr gut. Genau.
Und wieder zurück.
Jawohl, genau.
Und ganz wichtig,
das steht auch im Lehrmittel:
Wir versuchen, den GES zu behalten,
aber nicht um jeden Preis.
Wenn ihr alles versucht, aber den
GES nicht halten könnt und merkt,
dass ihr ihn verliert,
dann macht ihr besser das hier:
Und wir hoffen,
sie nicht einsetzen zu müssen.
Aber wenn sie sie doch brauchen,
müssen sie bereit sein.
Ja, so.
Yves Chappuis muss einmal pro Jahr
zur Schiessprüfung.
Heute ist es wieder so weit.
Wir schiessen grundsätzlich
in den Torso, inklusive Kopf.
Immer hierhin schiessen.
Wir schiessen 50 Schuss.
Ein Schuss, ein Punkt.
Bestanden hat man,
wenn man 40 Punkte hat.
Bereit!
Wer diese Prüfung nicht besteht,
darf nicht mehr
in den bewaffneten Einsatz.
Die Linie ist frei.
Wir gehen vor die Scheibe
und werten es aus.
Drei gingen daneben.
Ich schoss nicht präzise genug.
Jemand, der sagt, er sei
beim Schiesstest nicht aufgeregt,
blufft gewaltig.
Nein, es gibt schon
eine gewisse Anspannung.
Ich weiss, dass ich schiessen kann,
aber trotzdem.
Im Ernstfall
sollen solche Schüsse töten.
Drei Schuss. Bereit!
Bereit!
Stopp! Polizei!
Dani: 43. Markus: 46. Yves: 47.
Alle haben bestanden.
Ich gratuliere.
Danke.
- Nächstes Jahr wieder.
Ihr könnt jetzt nach hinten gehen,
um zu manipulieren.
Super. Tipptopp.
Drei habe ich verschenkt,
aber es reichte.
47 Punkte von 50.
Ich bin stolz. Super!
Die Waffe
war schon einige Male gezogen.
Zum Glück musste ich sie
aber noch nie einsetzen.
Man setzt sich
natürlich damit auseinander:
Was ist,
wenn ich sie einsetzen muss?
Aber insgeheim hofft man natürlich,
dass man diese Erfahrung nie macht,
dass man sie einsetzen muss.
Es ist natürlich nichts Angenehmes.
Man gerät dabei selbst
mit dem Gesetz in Konflikt.
Wenn man jemanden schwer verletzt
oder sogar tötet,
ist das psychisch und mental eine
Riesengeschichte zum Verarbeiten,
aber es wird auch juristisch
aufgearbeitet.
In der Schweiz
schiesst die Polizei selten.
Wer schiesse,
stehe mit einem Bein im Knast,
heisst es unter Polizisten.
* Spannungserzeugende Musik *
Vorwärts! Go, go, go!
Vorne rechts. Ist bei dir gut?
- Ja.
Okay.
An der Polizeischule in Hitzkirch
trainieren die Baselbieterin
Jana Stierli und ihre Kollegen
heute
für die ultimative Eskalationsstufe.
Vorwärts! Go, go, go!
* Spannungserzeugende Musik *
In einem Gebäude hat ein Amokläufer
oder ein Terrorist
zu schiessen begonnen.
Wer zuerst vor Ort ist,
muss eingreifen.
In solchen Fällen
geht es um Sekunden.
Bis die Spezialeinheit kommt,
ist vielleicht schon alles vorbei.
Denkt daran:
Seid ihr zu zweit unterwegs,
also im Team verschiebt,
schauen alle über die Schulter.
Macht es immer gleich: einfach.
Einfach funktioniert.
Alles andere funktioniert nicht.
Tempo gut?
- Tempo ist gut.
Ein bisschen zu langsam.
Ein bisschen zu langsam? Ah, okay.
Die angehenden Polizistinnen
und Polizisten
trainieren verschiedene Formationen.
In diesen
würden sie im Ernstfall vorrücken.
Halbzeit für Jana Stierli
in ihrer Ausbildung.
Wir haben in diesem halben Jahr
sicher sehr viel gelernt,
wenn ich
an den ersten Tag zurückdenke.
Ja, sehr eindrücklich für mich -
vom Theoretischen her,
vom Praktischen.
Ja, wir haben uns wirklich
sehr viel Wissen angeeignet.
* Spannungserzeugende Musik *
Im Ernstfall müssten Nando Wüthrich
und seine Kollegen versuchen,
den Amokläufer oder den Terroristen
so schnell wie möglich zu stellen
und zu erschiessen,
falls er sich nicht ergibt.
Jetzt machen wir voll, oder?
Nein, wie wir es gelernt haben.
- Ah, ja.
Du hältst sie mir auf.
- Okay.
Was soll ich?
"Polizei! Rauskommen!"?
- Ja.
(Beide) Polizei! Rauskommen!
Die Tür halten.
- Die Tür halten.
Dann gehe ich rein.
Ich sehe nichts. Es gibt eine Wand.
Ich sehe nicht in die Ecke.
Du siehst nicht in die Ecke?
- Nein.
Okay.
Die Fortschritte,
die die Aspirantinnen und Aspiranten
in den letzten Monaten machten,
sind offensichtlich.
Wir haben einige neue Themen,
die wir behandeln müssen.
Es gibt weitere Prüfungen.
Meines Erachtens ist die erste
Bilanz eigentlich eine gute Basis.
Und jetzt geht es darum,
die komplexeren Fälle
und Situationen zu lösen.
Die Wahrscheinlichkeit,
dass sie das je brauchen, ist klein,
aber nicht bei null.
Man muss einfach wissen:
Als Polizist
muss man die Fähigkeit haben,
solche Eskalationsstufen bewältigen
und das Level im richtigen Moment
hochfahren zu können.
Man muss richtig funktionieren
und das Richtige tun,
aber auch die Fähigkeit haben,
im richtigen Moment -
oder in den meisten Momenten -
möglichst lange durchzuhalten,
aber sich auch nicht verrückt machen
und nicht in jedem
einen Terroristen zu sehen.
Was ist genau das Problem?
Er wollte sich erst
der Kontrolle entziehen.
Als ich ihn stoppte,
gab er mir direkt 100 Fr.
Für mich ist der Fall erledigt.
Aber wir müssen
die Personalien erfassen,
weil die Mehrfachtäterschaft
bestraft wird.
Geht es nur um die Personalien?
Bei Kollegen.
- Guten Abend!
Hallo! Guten Abend.
- Good evening.
Do you speak English?
Der Schwarzfahrer sagt,
er sei aus Nigeria, wohne in Italien,
besuche Freunde in Frankreich und
wolle in der Schweiz eins trinken.
Das ist ein Ausweis aus Italien.
- Das ist eine ID.
Eine ID aus Italien.
- So ein Grenzausweis oder so.
Er ist nicht ausgeschrieben.
- Eben.
Also von unserer Seite ...
- Das Ausweisdokument ...
Die Busse hat er bezahlt.
- Dann ist es erledigt.
Danke.
- Alles klar.
Auf Wiedersehen.
Für uns
ist das hier in Allschwil erledigt.
Wir können nach Biel-Benken fahren.
Die Nachtschicht
bleibt unspektakulär: eine Lärmklage.
Lärm?
Soll ich mal zum Ohrenarzt? Ich höre
nie Lärm, wenn es gemeldet wird.
Die Anwohner
reklamierten wegen Jugendlichen.
Dort unten sitzen sie.
- Guten Abend zusammen.
Guten Abend.
- Guten Abend.
Alles klar?
- Ja.
Laute Musik, oder?
- Okay.
Ist gut.
Es gab eine Meldung, dass
die Nachbarn nicht schlafen können.
Entschuldigung.
Der eher grössere Teil
sind schon solche Sachen -
gerade jetzt im Sommer.
Die Leute sind empfindlich,
weil sie drinnen sein mussten.
Die Jungen wollen raus.
Und jetzt
kommen natürlich diese Meldungen.
Aber wir haben Verständnis -
für beide Seiten.
V.a. für die Jungen, die rauswollen.
In Yves Chappuis' Alltag
geht es oft um Bagatellen
und nur selten um Leben und Tod.
Bis er als Polizist
seine erste Leiche gesehen habe,
seien drei Jahre vergangen.
Er und seine Patrouillenpartnerin
wurden zum Haus einer Frau geschickt,
die plötzlich
nicht mehr zur Arbeit erschien.
Man sah durch eine Scheibe,
dass dort ein Körper lag.
Wir waren allein
und mussten die Tür aufbrechen.
Das war ein komisches Gefühl.
Wir wussten nicht,
was uns dort erwartete.
Meine Kollegin
wollte diese Aufgabe nicht machen.
Da blieb nur noch einer übrig.
Ich brach die Tür auf.
Der Körper rollte mir entgegen.
Das war sehr gruselig.
Es war natürlich sehr ungewohnt.
Aber man wusste
durch die ganze Ausbildung,
was einen erwartet,
also was passieren kann.
Vom Anblick her
war es nicht so schlimm,
aber es war ein toter Mensch.
Ja, es war schon sehr schräg.
Um solche Situationen geht es heute
an der Polizeischule in Hitzkirch.
Nando Wüthrich und eine Kollegin
werden als Patrouille
vor Ort geschickt.
Ist es hier?
- Ja.
Ah, hier. Guten Tag.
Polizei Basel-Landschaft,
Wüthrich mein Name.
Was ist passiert?
Ich habe meinen Nachbarn seit
zwei, drei Tagen nicht mehr gesehen.
Normalerweise sehe ich ihn jeden Tag
oder fast jeden Tag.
Herr Burgener!
- Ruedi!
Herr Burgener, sind Sie zu Hause?
Ich habe es ja gesagt:
Es ist schon etwas seltsam.
Ist gut?
- Ja.
Herr Burgener?
Oh, da liegt jemand.
Ein Toter.
Es stinkt auch nach Verwesung.
- Ja.
Wir haben alles abgesperrt.
Wir warten auf den Arzt.
- Gut.
Ab dem jetzigen Zeitpunkt
ist der Leichnam
eigentlich zuhanden des Staates
sichergestellt.
Und der Staat untersucht
den Leichnam und stellt fest,
ob es Spuren einer Dritteinwirkung
gibt oder eben nicht.
Die Todesart muss geklärt sein.
Die Todesursache muss nach
der Legalinspektion geklärt sein.
Die Identität muss geklärt sein
und der Todeszeitpunkt
muss festgelegt werden.
Ja, ich habe
schon mal einen Toten gesehen.
Das war im Zusammenhang mit
einem verstorbenen Familienmitglied,
von dem man sich ein letztes Mal
verabschieden konnte.
Aber sonst habe ich noch nie
einen Toten gesehen.
Also: Hier sehe ich Alkoholkonsum.
Eine Flasche lag schon im Bett.
Und Zigaretten. Ob er
etwas aus dem Regal getrunken hat?
Sonst keine Gegenstände.
So weit alles normal.
Er hielt ja auch
eine Flasche in der Hand.
Das WC.
Jetzt müssen sie
nach möglichen Hinweisen suchen.
Habt ihr in der Wohnung
nichts anderes mehr gefunden?
Nein.
Ausser mehreren Alkoholflaschen
sahen wir nichts Auffälliges.
Dort liegt ein Portemonnaie.
Holt ihr es? Auf dem Tisch.
Jetzt habt ihr dieses Portemonnaie.
Es ist leer.
Worauf könnte das hinweisen?
Raub.
- Das ist genau ein Raub.
Geht immer vom Schlimmsten aus!
Wenn ihr vom Schlimmsten ausgeht,
werdet ihr keine Fehler machen.
Dann habt ihr hoch angesetzt.
Nach dem sterilen Rollenspiel
bekommt der Tod jetzt ein Gesicht.
Ein Psychologe
der Kantonspolizei Bern
zeigt Nando Wüthrich und
seinen Kollegen Bilder von Leichen,
die man nur schwer verdauen kann -
von Menschen, die sich z.B.
erschossen oder erhängt haben.
Oder - was jetzt eben kommt - alles,
was Personenunfälle sind.
Eben: Suizid, indem man sich
von einem Zug überfahren lässt.
* Nando räuspert sich. *
Auch kein schönes Bild.
Dieser Zug fuhr nicht schnell.
Es sind grosse Teile.
Ihr seht also:
Es zerreisst die Leute.
Was mache ich mir für Gedanken, wenn
ich hier beim Aufräumen helfen muss?
Und im Polizistenjargon
nennt man das "fötzeln".
Wir müssen fötzeln.
Denkt daran:
Wir Blaulichtorganisationen ...
... haben
einen brandschwarzen Humor.
Ist das verboten?
- Nein.
Es gehört zur Verarbeitung.
- Genau.
Es gehört zur Verarbeitung,
zur Psychohygiene.
Das hilft,
sich auch wieder zu befreien.
Was ganz wichtig ist:
Ihr dürft Sprüche machen,
aber ihr müsst euch überlegen,
wo und in welchem Rahmen.
Besonders sensibel müsse man sein,
wenn man
sog. Todesnachrichten überbringe.
Für euch gibt es folgendes Szenario:
Unten auf dem Fussgängerstreifen
ist ein Verkehrsunfall passiert.
Ein Fussgänger
oder eine Fussgängerin
wurde auf dem Fussgängerstreifen
von einem Auto angefahren.
Angefahren?
- Angefahren.
Diese Person
wurde aber so schwer verletzt,
dass sie
noch auf der Unfallstelle starb.
Ihr habt anhand der Identitätskarte
herausgefunden: Es ist Frau Müller.
Frau Müller
ist verheiratet mit Herrn Müller.
Sie haben keine Kinder.
Sie wohnen in diesem Appartement.
Gut. Bist du bereit?
- Ja.
Gut.
Ih! Die Polizei? Guten Tag!
- Guten Tag, Herr Müller.
Was ist passiert?
Wüthrich mein Name
von der Polizei Basel-Landschaft.
Das ist meine Patrouillenpartnerin.
- Ah, eine Namensvetterin.
Guten Tag, Frau Müller!
Ist etwas passiert?
Dürften wir reinkommen?
Wir müssten mit Ihnen reden.
Kommen Sie nur!
Aber wir haben heute Hochzeitstag.
Ich will etwas Schönes
zum Abendessen auftischen.
Ja.
Erzählen Sie! Was ist passiert?
Der Grund,
warum wir hier sind, Herr Müller:
Vor 30 Min.
ereignete sich ein Verkehrsunfall,
bei dem Ihre Frau involviert war.
- Ui, nein! Ist sie schwer verletzt?
In welchem Spital liegt sie?
- Sie erlitt schwere Verletzungen.
Ich muss Ihnen sagen,
dass sie noch am Unfallort verstarb.
Meine ... Meine Frau?
Du meine Güte!
Nein!
Ich kann ohne meine Frau nicht sein!
Nein, ich will nicht mehr sein!
Stopp! Stopp! Stopp!
* Schluchzen *
Kommen Sie wieder rein, Herr Müller.
Geht es?
Kommen Sie, wir setzen uns,
Herr Müller. Kommen Sie!
Nehmen Sie Platz!
Können wir Ihnen etwas bringen,
Herr Müller?
Gut, danke.
* Lachen *
Wie geht es euch?
- Es ist schwierig.
Wir wollten ...
Oder wir haben versucht,
dir bzw. dem Ehemann genug Zeit
zu geben, um das zu verarbeiten.
Es war schwierig zu merken, wann wir
dich wieder ansprechen sollten.
Und dann diese Reaktion,
die hat uns dann ...
Habt ihr sie erwartet?
- Nein, überhaupt nicht.
Es gibt zwei Varianten.
Es kann beides passieren.
Nämlich, dass jemand
wirklich lange still ist.
Es kam schon vor, dass eine Person
15 Min. lang still war.
Wie lange kam es euch vor?
- Ewig.
Ja.
Da stirbst du 1'000 Tode.
- Ja.
Und ich kann nichts machen.
Aushalten.
- Richtig.
Und das ist verdammt schwer.
Das waren jetzt nur 2 Min.
Also war das der richtige Ansatz,
den wir da verfolgten?
Perfekt! Perfekt! Perfekt!
Da gibt es nichts Negatives.
Cool gewesen.
Nein, bei uns überbringen
Kadermitarbeitende Todesnachrichten.
Sie haben diese Funktion
und sind geschult.
Aber ich war bei der Überbringung
auch schon dabei.
Klar, das ist nicht schön.
Man versucht natürlich,
möglichst sachte ranzugehen.
Aber irgendwann
muss man es ansprechen.
Das braucht viel Zeit.
Es kommen viele Fragen:
Warum? Wieso? Weshalb?
Es gibt im ersten Moment diese
Fassungslosigkeit und Ohnmacht.
Man versucht einfach,
möglichst empathisch zu sein
und die Leute in dieser schwierigen
Situation zu unterstützen.
Yves Chappuis sagt, als Polizist
müsse man lernen, sich abzugrenzen.
Und gleichzeitig
dürfe man nicht abstumpfen.
Jeder Mensch habe eine Geschichte -
und auf diese müsse man eingehen.
In diesem Fall auf einen jungen Mann,
der bei einem Ladendiebstahl
erwischt wurde.
* Spannungserzeugende Musik *
Guten Tag.
Ist das Büro dort hinten?
Ah ja, genau. Tipptopp!
Guten Tag miteinander.
Was ist passiert?
Er hat nicht alles gescannt.
Das dort schon, das hier nicht.
Und den Rest, zwei Colas,
trug er in der Jackentasche.
Okay. Und dann ging er raus?
- Ja.
Er bezahlte einen Teil
und ging mit dem Rest raus?
Nach der Kasse, jawohl.
Okay.
Und wo sind wir? Bei 17.25 Fr.?
Die Personalien überprüfen.
- Genau.
Und eine Anzeige natürlich.
- Jawohl.
Die müssen wir auch aufnehmen.
Was haben Sie
für einen Ausweis dabei?
Danke.
Können Sie die Maske runterziehen,
damit ich Ihr Gesicht sehe?
Okay, das ist der Lernfahrausweis.
Das ist gut.
Was ich noch sah:
zweimal Widerhandlung
und einmal Tätergewalt,
irgendetwas mit einer Verletzung.
Vielleicht bei ihm
noch schnell eine Aussage.
Der ganze Aufwand wegen 17.25 Fr.
Ja, klar, es ist Peanuts.
In allen Einkaufszentren der Schweiz
wird täglich
1'000-mal so viel gestohlen.
Aber das ist natürlich ...
Es geht nicht.
Wir überprüften diese Person
in unserem System und stellten fest,
dass noch andere Delikte passierten.
Es ist bei ihm
also nicht einfach der erste Fall.
Und ich denke, das geht so nicht.
Da muss man ein Zeichen setzen.
Ich taste Sie schnell ab.
Eine Frage zum Einkommen -
Sie müssen keine Angaben machen,
wenn Sie nicht wollen.
Was haben Sie
für ein Nettoeinkommen in Franken?
Keine Angaben?
Es gibt natürlich
verschiedene Menschen
und Reaktionen auf die Polizei.
Einige sind sehr anständig,
andere rebellieren auch
gegen das Vorgehen der Polizei.
Da muss man einfach zeigen,
wie das System läuft,
und bestimmt auftreten.
Und dann
kann man miteinander arbeiten.
Ja, ich mache so schnell, ich kann.
Ich mache nicht absichtlich langsam.
Ich fülle alles richtig aus,
dann können wir das hier beenden.
So, also, wir hätten alles.
Es gibt eine Anzeige
an die Staatsanwaltschaft.
Sie werden Bescheid bekommen.
Es gibt eine Busse
und allenfalls noch Massnahmen
oder Hausverbot von der Migros.
Aber das ist ihre Angelegenheit.
Schauen Sie,
dass Sie das nicht machen.
Ja.
- Das bringt Ihnen nur Ärger,
Umtriebe und am Schluss Mehrkosten.
- Ja.
Ist gut?
So.
Weisst du den Artikel noch?
- Ja, 252a.
Oh ja.
Nando Wüthrich
ist in einem einmonatigen Praktikum
in seinem Polizeikorps.
Das gibt eine Busse wegen Parkieren
ausserhalb des Parkfeldes.
Wir hatten
schon mehrere solcher Fälle.
Hier parkieren sie
auch immer wieder gerne.
Es ist unsere Pflicht, dass
auf der Strasse Ordnung herrscht.
Der angehende Polizist
kennt kein Pardon.
Ob ich ein Streber bin?
Ich versuche, in der Schule
so gut wie möglich zu sein
und auch hier so viel wie möglich
mitzunehmen und zu lernen.
Dazu bin ich hier.
Die vier Wochen sind begrenzt.
Ich muss jede Gelegenheit nutzen,
alles Mögliche mitzunehmen.
Polizisten seien Wölfe,
wurde Nando Wüthrich am ersten Tag
an der Polizeischule gesagt.
Dorthin
müsse auch er sich entwickeln.
Ob ich ein Wolf geworden bin?
Das ist schwer zu sagen.
Langsam, aber sicher.
Er braucht noch etwas Zeit.
Er ist ein Jungwolf.
Nein, er macht es gut.
Ich bin zufrieden.
Jana Stierli, die andere Jungwölfin,
patrouilliert auch
auf den Baselbieter Strassen.
Du musst schauen,
dass das Blinkzeug genug Strom hat.
Sie wird als Verstärkung für die
Rettung verirrter Kinder angefordert.
Genauer: für Entenkinder.
Die waren vorher auf der Strasse?
- Ja.
Okay.
Süss!
Hinter dem Zaun ist Grün 80.
Dort sind grosse Weiher,
in denen diese Entenfamilien leben.
Und wenn sie
einen Spaziergang machen,
fallen sie durch den Zaun
und landen auf der Autobahn.
Sie können nicht mehr weg.
Schliesslich sammeln wir sie ein
und bringen sie wohlbehalten
wieder zurück.
Ich bin zum ersten Mal
bei einer solchen Entenaktion dabei.
Es ist grundsätzlich
eine niedliche Sache.
Schön, dass man ihnen helfen kann.
Man blockiert halt den Verkehr,
aber ja, es bringt ja nur Gutes.
Nachher ist der Verkehr wieder frei,
und sie können besser fahren.
Der Plan ist, dass wir abziehen.
Wir fahren unten beim Joggeli durch
und laden Michi an der Birs
wieder ein,
damit er nicht wieder
über die Autobahn fahren muss.
Okay.
Die Entenkinder sollen im Idealfall
zu ihrer Mutter gebracht werden,
damit sie nicht
vom nächsten Fuchs gefressen werden.
Ich konnte die Entenfamilie
in der Schachtel zur Birs bringen.
Ich wartete einen Moment,
bis ich die Mutter oben sah.
Als ich sie sah,
habe ich die Schachtel
sachte an den Rand gestellt.
Die Jungs konnten aussteigen
und ihre Mutter fand sie wieder.
Tipptopp!
Freitag. Feierabendverkehr.
Haben Sie dort
alkoholische Getränke konsumiert?
Guten Abend.
Haben Sie
alkoholische Getränke konsumiert?
Nein.
Nando Wüthrich sucht sog. FiaZ-Fälle.
FiaZ bedeutet
Fahren in angetrunkenem Zustand.
Ich mache gerne Verkehrskontrollen.
Es ist immer wieder
eine Überraschung,
wen man in der Kontrolle antrifft.
Man weiss nie genau,
was auf einen zukommt.
Es fordert sehr viel Gespür,
zu erkennen oder einzuschätzen,
wie sich die Person verhält,
ob sie vielleicht
etwas getrunken hat.
Ja.
Der Kollege
macht mit Ihnen einen Alkoholtest.
Wann hatten Sie den letzten Schluck?
Vor 30 Min.
- Vor 30 Min., okay.
Haben Sie das schon mal gemacht?
- Ja.
Dann wissen Sie,
wie es funktioniert.
Ja.
Wichtig ist, ohne Unterbruch
5-6 Sek. reinzupusten.
Nicht allzu fest.
Ich halte es sonst.
Perfekt. Das reicht schon.
Wir sehen auch gleich das Resultat.
* Piepsen *
0,35.
0,35 mg/l.
Das wären dann 0,7 Promille.
Die Grenze liegt bei 0,49 Promille.
- Ja.
Ich sage mal,
das war ein Bierchen zu viel.
Jetzt ist es so: Das ist
ein FiaZ light, wie wir das nennen.
D.h.,
Sie dürfen nicht mehr weiterfahren.
Es gibt eine Anzeige
an die Staatsanwaltschaft.
In dem Fall, ja.
Wenn es so warm ist,
muss man aufpassen.
In einer Zimmerei
ist das am Freitagabend normal.
Es ist nicht das erste Mal,
dass ich in eine Kontrolle komme.
Daher bin ich etwas ...
- ... überrascht.
Die Kollegen
bereiten schnell das Dokument vor.
Also, das hier hat damit zu tun, ob
Sie den Wert anerkennen oder nicht.
D.h., in Ihrem Fall, also bis 0,4,
können Sie es noch anerkennen,
wenn Sie sagen,
dass Sie den Wert von 0,35,
den wir gemessen haben, anerkennen.
Wenn nicht,
müssen wir zum Posten fahren
und nochmals eine Beweissicherung
mit dem Atemalkoholmessgerät machen.
Sie haben auch die Möglichkeit,
eine Blutprobe zu verlangen,
wenn Sie wollen.
Wenn Sie das so akzeptieren,
müssen Sie hier ein Ja hinschreiben
und hier unterschreiben.
Und hier noch unterschreiben, genau.
Genau. Danke schön.
Er muss sein Auto stehen lassen
und darauf warten,
dass ihn jemand abholt.
Ob ich mit ihm Mitleid habe?
Nein.
Ich finde das immer gefährlich,
wenn Leute
alkoholisiert Auto fahren.
Ich finde generell, dass man
das Auto nicht mehr anfassen
und stehen lassen sollte,
wenn man etwas getrunken hat.
So gesehen habe ich kein Mitleid.
Er sagte selber,
dass er damit gerechnet habe,
dass er noch fahren müsse.
Dann, finde ich, ist er
das falsche Risiko eingegangen.
Und so geht es weiter:
Der Puls ist etwas erhöht.
Abschlussprüfungen
an der Polizeischule.
Wüthrich, Roggenmoser.
Häusliche Gewalt.
Häusliche Gewalt? Das ist super.
Schaffen sie es oder nicht?
Ich habe das Gefühl, dass ich
eine megaschlechte Note bekomme.
SWISS TXT / Access Services
puretype gmbh - 2021